millions of Americans are sharing
stories and pictures this morning about
the historic eclipse did you see it
photos taken across the country capture
the moments yesterday when the moon
passed right in front of the Sun large
crowds gathered coast-to-coast along the
70 mile wide path of totality Jamie
yuccas is in the town of Madras Oregon
where many visitors are still trying to
get home Jamie I saw you last night you
had a great view good morning I did I
had an excellent view Gail it was so
much fun and as you can see people are
packing up right now
Madras is home to 6,200 people but had
planned to host a hundred thousand now
crowds at camp sites like this one
slowly trickled in over several days but
now that there is this mass exit the
National Guard has been called in to
help out from Madras organ all the way
to Charleston South Carolina I'm
speechless I'm literally speechless
millions of Americans looked up as
darkness descended in the middle of the
day this is something that I will be
dreaming about and thinking about for
the rest of my life
crowds erupted in Carbondale Illinois
where the darkness lasted longer than
nearly anywhere else in the country
satellite imagery showed the moon
shadows sweeping across the country in
roughly 90 minutes can you see the
shadow the elliptical shadow projected
on the cloud cover below us the view
looked just as stunning from the air I
just saw day lights full return revealed
miles of growing traffic intersecting
the eclipses path when do you hope to
get home
it's an adventure gridlock extended to
this Airport in Oregon
where more than 400 planes were
reportedly waiting to take off but for
many the holdup did not overshadow
nature's rare spectacle in the sky
actually getting to see one in person
was and that's a price you gotta pay
okay
if you miss this one don't worry the
next one is in 2024 and it will cover
much of the eastern and central us
Margaret the path of totality Jamie
yuccas thank you